So, ja, ich bin bereit. Wir können loslegen. Ganz kurz mal, dodona, dodona, massiv übersteuert, buongiorno, senora, bella donna, andiamo, buongiorno, senora, bella donna, andiamo, buongiorno, senora, bella donna, andiamo. Hey Schatz, das ist der Podcast, den ich dir zeigen wollte, der, dem die immer Italienisch singen. Tante Trude tanzt mit Theo Tango Twist und Tarantella. Tante Trude tanzt mit Theo Tango Twist und Tarantella. Tante Trude tanzt mit Theo Tango Twist und Tarantella. Was ist denn Tarantella? Das ist auch eine Art, ein rhythmischer Bewegungsablauf, Tanz genannt, aus dem fernen Bolivio. Mach mal eine andere Reizung, ich bin sofort fertig mit meinem privaten Gedöns hier. Meine Damen und Herren, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe des Pod, Pod, Pod, Pod, Cast, Cast heee heee geil gah heee heee mit mein Geld mit Stefan Titzetitze und Florentin Will ill ill ill ill. Ich begrüsse dich dich dich dich dich heute in diesem Raum die Möbel fehlen komplett, komplett, komplett, das ist alles ein bisschen Chaos, Chaos, Chaos, sorry.
Leider müssen wir komplett das Impressum von unserem neuen Podcast ändern, denn Stefan R ist bekannt als Witzfigur, jeder kennt ihn, er hat sofort ein Lächeln auf dem Mund, wenn man seinen Namen hört, aber Stefan hat es sich nicht länger lumpen lassen, er möchte die Spiele nicht mehr mitmachen, er hat seinen alten Namen abgeworfen, Stefan hat seit dieser Woche einen neuen Namen. So, ich fand meinen Namen schön. Also ich wollte jetzt nicht einen komplett neuen Namen. Ich dachte mir, so eine kleine Änderung wäre ganz schön. Ich heisse ab sofort, und das ist jetzt kein Scheiß, machen oft sind wir bekannt für unsere Scherze, das stimmt nicht diesmal, das ist eine werbare Geschichte, ich heiße ab sofort Stefan Tietze Tietze. Ja, vielleicht können wir auch Beweisfotos posten, wie kam es denn dazu? Also ich habe den neuen Reisepass beantragt, wie ich auch in diesem Podcast glaube ich mal erzählt habe, weiss nicht, vielleicht habe ich da wegen Langeweile rausgeschrieben. Für Fans der Reisepass-Plotline, die nicht genug getragen haben, was ist denn jetzt? Geil dass die Storyline mal irgendwann in Folge 3 angefangen hat, dann in Folge 17 mal wieder eine Rolle gespielt hat und jetzt wieder aktuell wird. Diese Storyline ist so weit dazu führen, dass ein Fehler gemacht wurde, weil ich war am 1. März da, das war der erste Tag der neuen Reisepässe, und dann ist der Fehler unterlaufen und ich heiße jetzt in einem offiziellen Ausweisdokument Stefan Michael Tietze-Tietze.
Zweimal Tietze und ich ... Doppeltietze. Und es ist so ein weirder Moment, wenn man am Amt steht und lachen muss. Weil die meisten Leute sind genervt. Die, die arbeiten, sind genervt, aber hallo, die Leute, die da sind, wollen nicht da sein, sind genervt. Die Leute, die da dran sind, sind genervt, weil sie so lange warten mussten. Die Leute, die warten, sind genervt, weil sie noch nicht dran sind. Alle sind genervt, und ich stehe mitten in diesem Raum und muss lautlos lachen, weil mein Ausweisdokument mir bescheinigt, Stefan Tiese-Tiese zu heißen. Ich hab ein Foto davon gemacht, ich schieb's mir rum. Aber wie gut ist das denn, ey? Würdest du nicht auch gerne einen lustigen Namen haben? Bist du auch so ein lustiger Erfolger? Ich hab mir tatsächlich diese Woche überlegt, weil ich hatte ein Gespräch mit einer Kollegin, also was heißt Gespräch, eingeredet haben. Bist du auch so ein Lustiger. Ich habe mir tatsächlich diese Woche überlegt, weil ich hatte ein Gespräch mit einer Kollegin, also was heißt Gespräch, sie hat gearbeitet, während ich auch hier eingeredet habe. Streitgespräch. Diese Art von Gesprächen, wo in der Mitte des Gesprächs der eine Gesprächspartner sagt, redest du mit mir? Diese Art von Gespräch. Oder ganz gut, wenn du den Kopfhörer abnimmst und sagst, bitte was? Genau, und man hat bis dahin gemerkt, ich dachte, die hat nur eine seltsame Frisur, ich habe gar nicht gesehen, dass das Kopfhörer sind. Und da kam dann das Thema auf, von wegen reimende Fondnachnamen, und ich habe mir überlegt, müsste ich eigentlich mein Kind Till nennen, Till Will? Eigentlich als Comedy Ambassador, wo ich mich sehe, dass ich diese Wilden ein bisschen mehr Schmunzeln auf die Lippen zaubern möchte, dachte ich mir, eigentlich muss man das mal. Eigentlich muss man das mal. Könnt ihr mal mit dem Collage machen, wo Körpergeräusche von Floridin will, die Anregten beeinflussen, wo mittlerweile sein Sprechen beeinflussen, ist letzte Woche auch schon vorgekommen. Macht mal mit dem Collage daraus. Auch das Ende Moin Moins, einfach mal alles, was ihr habt von ihm, rausnehmen, wo er anfängt, wo sein Satz anfängt, den er abbrechen muss, wegen Körpergeräusch.
Ja, übrigens für Leute da draußen, die es gar nicht wissen und die zu wenig Zeit haben, die ganzen Podcast-UFO-Folgen zu hören, es gibt mittlerweile einen YouTube-Kanal, der fast ausschließlich Best-of von Podcast-UFO-Folgen bringt.
Dieser YouTube-Kanal heißt Tomb Raider Fan und er bringt Best-ofs der Podcast-UFO.
Und das Magische an diesem Kanal ist, dass die Best-ofs, die da zusammengeschnitten wurden, länger sind als die eigentlichen Folgen des Podcast-Ufos. Was ganz interessant ist, wie das genau funktioniert, weiß ich bis heute nicht, aber ich glaube, es heißt wirklich Tomb Raider. Der Fan könnt jetzt alle mal gucken. Ja, aber das führt ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung. Man denkt, das sind bestimmt Tomb Raider-Videos und dann sind dann sind die Podcasts zu verfolgen. Genau, was denken denn die Leute? Tomb Raider Fan 1987. Zwei Fragen. Diese Person. 1987, das ist wirklich unsere Zielgruppe. Wann bist du geboren? 91. 91, okay. Dass Leute älter sind als wir, die unseren Podcast hören, uns beim Leben zu hören, finde ich ein bisschen befremdlich. Aber hört da mal rein, wir können ja vielleicht so eine Das-Podcast-Uvo-Empfehlungsrunde machen. Also ich empfehle euch diese Woche Tomb Raider-Fan 1987. Hast du irgendwas, was du den... Ja, Funny or Die. Ja? Okay. Sonst auch irgendwas, irgendeinen Podcast, du den empfehlen kannst? Ne, fällt mir gerade nichts ein. Alles klar. Fällt mir gerade gar nichts ein. Ansonsten, ja, interessant zu sehen, dass diese Reisepass-Plotline endlich ihr Ende nimmt. Würde mich mal wieder freuen, wenn es mal wieder die Kampffisch-Plotline, mal wieder ein Revival.
Wie soll das passieren?
Ja, aber keine Ahnung, ein gewisser Triebbuchautor kann sich da was einfallen lassen, die Flashbacks oder so.
Das Aquarium-Equipment ist jetzt in meinem Kellerverlies.
Ja.
Und es ist wirklich warm, ich habe wirklich so einen Kellerverlies.
Was ist da noch alles?
Die Lampe, die da vorher, also mehrere Lampen, die vorher in der Wohnung hingen, als ich die bewohnt habe, dann so eine große, so ein Badezimmer, Spiegel, wo man dann auch denkt, warum braucht man ein Spiegel im Badezimmer? Aber jetzt haben alle Spiegel rausgenommen, so, ich habe keinen Spiegel in meiner Wohnung, ich habe verachte Spiegel. Jetzt weißt du nicht mehr, wer du bist, du duschst immer die falsche Person. Ich denke immer so, what? Und dann sehe ich mich manchmal hier, auch auf Videos oder sowas, wenn man mal gefilmt wird, denke ich immer, wow, das ist so gut. Ich soll mir mit der Cam eigentlich. Ja, das soll ich immer wieder ein bisschen waschen. Vielleicht bist du auch ein Vampir irgendwann und merkst es gar nicht. Das ist halt die große Gefahr. Und da steht ein Tisch drin, den ich mir selber gekauft habe, bis heute nicht wieder verkauft habe. Ich habe den ausrangiert, weil er zu niedrig ist. Der ist zu niedrig. Der ist wirklich nur ... Fehlkauf, Stefan! Nein, das geht weiter darüber hinaus. Der ist zehn Zentimeter gross nur. Und das habe ich nicht gewusst. Ich habe den gekauft bei Ikea und dachte mir so, wow, ich brauche so einen Wohnzimmertisch. Und dann war das halt so ein Lounge-Tisch. Vielleicht ein Teller einfach nur, ein hoher Teller. Der ist so breit, so eine Rechteckform hat der, aber der ist wirklich nur so 20 cm hoch und dann habe ich gedacht, da fehlen noch jetzt Teile.
Man baut das ja auch mit so einer Haltung auf, wenn das jetzt schlecht aussieht, ist das meine Schuld und nicht Ikea. Ikea macht das schon ganz richtig, weil die halt das so ein bisschen so ein Tars draus machen und die Schuld so ein bisschen wegschieben, so wegwerfen wie so eine Handgranate. Und dann stand plötzlich dann vor mir auf der relativ hohen Couch, normal grossen Couch, stand dann ein kleiner Tisch, der mehr wie so eine, man hat ein Paket auf dem Boden vergessen, Höhe hatte. Und das war ein bisschen seltsam. Und dann habe ich den dann irgendwann ausrangig und gegen den richtigen Tisch gekauft. Aber das war so eine Lounge-Optik. Das ist auch so ein Gegenstand, den ich mir in meinem Leben nie kaufen werde, Das ist ein Couch-Tisch. So dieser zu niedrige Tisch. Nie würde ich mir das kaufen. Ich habe jetzt so einen Holztisch, einen Massivholztisch. Sieht richtig cool aus, wenn da so die Whisky-Flaschen und die Bierflaschen draufstehen und die meine ganzen Coke-Lines, die man da hat. Weißt du, Stefan Tietz ist auch eine der Personen, der dich einlädst und sich nach Hause dann schön mal einen Drink, schön Whisky kippen und dann kriegst du das Whiskyglas und dann sagt er, ja, aber bitte nimm die Untersetzer für die Gleisers. Oh, das sind die schlimme. So, das ist halt dann so ein Stefan-Tietzer-Abend, wo du einfach weißt, die Nacht wird wild, wenn es schon so losgeht. Ich liebe Kratzer im Tisch, ich glaube, ich bin einer der wenigen Menschen, die Kratzer am Tisch lieben, aber ich war im Zuge bei der Bachelorarbeiten mal bei meinem Professor zu Gast. Und bei dem ist das so, bei dem muss man dann auch natürlich auf seinem Echtholztisch muss man dann Untersesser drauf haben und so.
Und am schlimmsten sind Spiralblöcke. Da wollte ich nämlich einen Spiralblock nehmen, um meinen Laptop nicht auf den Tisch zu stellen, und dann hat er gesagt, nein, die sind noch viel schlimmer. Also deinen Spiralblock auf den Laptop. Genau, umgekehrt. Prioritäten. Apropos Prioritäten. Falls ihr nicht wisst, was soll ich mir demnächst zuerst anhören von Florentin? Soll ich mir mal ein Moment angucken? Soll ich mir das Podcast-Sofo anhören? Soll ich mir irgendwas von Stefan anhören? Nein, Florentin hat was Neues am Start. Florentin hat eine ganz, ich hätte schon bessere Überleitung machen können im Laufe des Podcasts, aber ich habe es mir für diesen Moment auch überlegt. Florentin hat ein ganz, ganz tolles neues Projekt gestartet, was ich selber mit großer Freude höre. Und zwar redet er über den Psychoanalytiker Jacques Lacan und hat dann mit einem Podcast mit einem dem Führenden, was ich spannend finde, weil dass er dich mit dir hinabwürdigt, um mit dir diesen Podcast aufzunehmen, der große Lacan-Experte Rolf Niemitz. Rolf Niemitz, ja. Ich habe tatsächlich ein neues Podcast-Projekt, ein Solo-Podcast. Den Lacast. Den Lacast, der einmal im Monat rauskommt. Wir haben drei Folgen schon aufgenommen und bei jeder Folge war es immer so, dass Stefan verregnet draußen vor dem Fenster stand und reingeguckt hat und dann immer so mitgeredet hat. Mit dem Lacan-Shirt auf. Ja, aber es ist mein Solo-Podcast. Stefan ist nicht dabei, es tut mir leid, aber für alle, es ist ein ernstes Projekt, wenn man eine andere Seite von mir entdecken will, guckt mal vorbei, lacast, L-A-C-A-S-T, punkt der Ehe oder auf Facebook, guckt ihr, guckt ihr, guckt ihr. Es ist ja interessant, weil jetzt mal so eine neue Zielgruppe für mich erschlossen wird, zu ernsthafter Leute einfach. Weil wir sind ja umgeben, alle Leute, die uns mögen, mögen Comedy und wir mögen Comedy und wir denken ja, alle mögen Comedy und Leute, die wir nicht erreichen, für die sind wir einfach nicht lustig genug, die müssen wir irgendwie anders erreichen, aber es gibt auch mehr als genug Menschen, die einfach überhaupt keinen Humor und Comedy in ihrem Leben haben, null. Und die schließe ich jetzt so ein bisschen. Ich will es alle erschließen, du willst alle haben. Ich will alle haben, ich will einfach alle haben. Und ich habe einfach schon so ein paar, der Podcast ist so aufgebaut, dass ich so ein bisschen Fragen stelle und der Experte halt antwortet, also irgendwie 90 Prozent Redeanteil hat.
Und die schönste Kritik, die ich zu dem Podcast bekommen habe, war, ja, sehr interessanter Podcast, wenn man sich die Fragen und Meinungen von Florentin Will wegdenkt. So denke ich so, nice, danke. Aber das ist halt ein anderer Level halt so, da bist du dann, hast du ein bisschen ein grösseres Heiferspeck. Aber hört mal rein. Nee, ich finde es vor allem cool, weil ich finde es spannend, wie sehr und wie tief
du dich mit Psychoanalyse auseinandergesetzt hast. Das ist eine geheime Leidenschaft. Obwohl du tatsächlich eigentlich ein sehr unausredlichener Mensch bist, dem ich eine geringe emotionale Intelligenz unterstellen würde. Das ist bei mir nicht böse, aber du bist soziale Beziehungen und so was und wie man mit Menschen reden sollte und wie man sich in Meetings verhalten sollte, ist nicht so deins. Und deswegen finde ich es einfach, ich finde es total cool, weil in meinem Kopf hat sich liebe Fragezeichen in meinem Kopf. Und das ist ein Fragezeichen, was sich gebildet hat, wie sich jemand, der dann so ist, so sehr für Psychoanalyse, oder gerade deswegen vielleicht für Psychoanalyse interessiert. Ja. Hört mal rein. Hört auf jeden Fall mal rein. Ich bin gespannt auf euer Feedback. Ja, bist du wirklich? Ja. Bist du bei uns auch gespannt aufs Feedback? Nee. Ich muss aber auch sagen, mir ist auch aufgerufenfallen, dass viele Leute sich nicht für Humor interessieren. Weil mancherweise bin ich bei einer Preisverleihung im Jahr. Das ist der Comedypreis. Oh ja. So, das ist cool. Also das ist auch nicht cool, das ist auch furchtbar. Aber auf einer anderen Ebene wie der, wo ich jetzt war, die Goldene Kamera. Und die Goldene Kamera ist eine unfassbare Veranstaltung. Das sind schon so ein bisschen die deutschen Oscars. Auf jeden Fall. Es ist ein bisschen schwer, den Überblick zu bewahren. Es gibt ja so viele, so Grimmepreis und Fernsehpreis und Goldene Kamera und dann Otto und Bambi und so ganz so Crap. Schwierig einzuordnen, aber um es kurz mal einzuordnen. Ich bin hin und dann wollte ich halt, es war in Hamburg, ich bin mit dem Zug gefahren, ich wollte halt nicht mega einen Koffer mitnehmen oder so, sondern meinen Rucksack und hab dann meinen Anzug in meinen Rucksack gestopft, wie man das halt so macht. So und dann dachte ich mir, fuck, kannst du mit dem Zeichen an den Anzug da hinkommen? Und dann stand auf der Einladung sogar, Smoking und Fliege bitte kommen. Das war der Dresscode. Das heißt, ich bin weit unterm Dresscode, nicht nur mit dem Anzug, sondern mit einem Zecknetz an den Anzug gekommen. Und es waren wirklich alle mit Fliege und Smoking gekommen. Und es war einfach krass. Also die haben sich alle drangehalten und es war wirklich eine krasse Veranstaltung einfach, mit heftigen Stars dann auch. Und das war eine ganz seltsame Veranstaltung, auch weil ich mit niemandem sprechen konnte, weil die alle eine ganz andere Sprache sprechen als ich. So Gags zu machen, kommen gar nicht an. Leute verlassen dann das Gespräch einfach und gehen weg. Das ist nicht wie ein Comedypreis, wo du lustige Leute kennenlernst und so weiter, das ist ja nicht. Vor allem, um kurz mal etwas ein Gefühl zu geben für die Größe, du wurdest von der Veranstaltung zur Toilette mit einem Golf-Caddy gefahren, von Leuten, die als Zirkus-Pagen gekleidet waren. Die Frauen hatten so große Frauenfedern, Verzierungen, die Männer hatten also ein Zirkusdirektor-Outfit an und es war einfach alles in so einem Zirkus-Thema und in der Mitte dieser großen Messehalle, wo diese Veranstaltung stattfindet, die Aftershop-Party, war einfach so ein Riesensüßigkeitenstand. Das sah aus wie Childish-Toccolaten-Fabrik. Es war einfach eine Menge, das war, kennst du diese kleinen Süßigkeiten, das sind so kleine Bällchen, so rote Bällchen. Die sind so mit Zucker glasiert und so und die schmecken so nach Beeren. Sehr lecker, davon waren Milliarden auf so einem grossen, größer als ich befindlichen Haufen aufgeschüttet und überall
Käse und dann gab es
bestimmt 20 Essensstände
und dann kam plötzlich die Blaskapelle rein
und dachte mir, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich los?
Dann in der einen Hälfte waren plötzlich Laserschwerter
und Star Wars Sachen,
wow, dann in der anderen Ecke war plötzlich
eine Kreuzfahrtausstellung,
wo man dann so VR-Brillen aufbekommen hat
um die Kreuzfahrt, dann waren Katja und ich, ich war mit Katja da, waren plötzlich auf so einem Schiff eine Stunde lang, weil wir diese VR-Brille aufbekommen haben. Es war die weirdeste Veranstaltung ever. So eine komische Größe, die die hatte. Es ist komisch, dass dann auch immer so dieser Business-Aspekt drin ist, dass dann so Leute so Werbung machen wollen, so für ihre Kreuzfahrten. Das sind die Multiplikatoren. Das kann man sich einfach nicht vorstellen, dass du die Oscar-Pfeilierung machst und dann danach irgendwie
After-Shop-Party, alle stehen da mit ihrer goldenen Statuette
und dann kommt dann irgendwie noch so Nestle
vorbar und sagt so, hey, habt ihr Lust, dieses
Pulver in eure Milch zu rühren? So, nein,
wir wollen jetzt gerade
rumgenießen. Das macht einfach alles kaputt,
so dieser massiv kommerzielle
Aspekt, den es ja beim Comedypreis auch gibt, da gibt es dann auch
so verschiedene Gissern, McCaffee macht
Kuchen und so. Aber der Comedypreis ist wirklich so, boah, der ist so eine Kaschemme dagegen. Aber deswegen mag ich ihn auch so. Ja, ich auch. Der hat wirklich so ein bisschen was Widerwägen. Ja, so einen richtigen, da geht niemand gerne hin, aber irgendwie alle lieben die Hässlichkeit davon. Und ich wusste auch nie, wer ich war, und da sind ganz viele Presseleute, aber die wollen auch niemanden verpassen, den sie vielleicht nicht kennen. Das heißt, da kommen ganz oft Leute zu dir, die dich fotografieren wollen. Und da bin ich einfach mal vorbeigegangen, habe immer so eine Hollywood-Star, ich halte meine Hand vor meinem Gesicht, gesteke ich und weitergegangen. Was clever ist, weil dann wahrscheinlich die Aufmerksamkeit noch weiter steigt. Ja, ja, aber das war auf jeden Fall eine unfassbare Veranstaltung. Und dann sind wir mit dem Golfcaddy die ganze Zeit darum gecruised, will ich nie wieder hin. War furchtbar. Aber Colin Farrell war da. Ein bisschen mehr zu aufdringlich. Nick Kirkman war auch, aber dann lebt die an einem dann die ganzen Abend, wenn man einmal mit der redet. Oh Gott, unangenehm. Das ist echt nervig. Das war echt krass. Das ist keine Lust. Es ist immer so ein bisschen, gerade bei den Hollywood-Stars, denke ich mir, das ist so ein bisschen wie dieses Woody Allen-Zitat irgendwie, ich möchte nicht Teil eines Klubs sein, der mich als Mitglied hat. So ist es auch so, diese Stars werden in dem Moment uninteressant, in dem sie bei der goldenen Kamera sind. Die Stars heben nicht die goldene Kamera, sondern die goldene Kamera zieht die Stars runter. Und auch wenn es Colin Farrell ist, denke ich mir, sehr gut, du Lappen, du bist auf der goldenen Kamera, ich bin auf der goldenen Kamera. Also wir sind schon so auf Augenhöhe dann irgendwo. Natürlich nicht, aber das zieht die runter. Das will ich dann gar nicht. Ja, das war ganz schön. Ich verliere dann das Glamour. Das ist auch wirklich schwierig, darüber jetzt Gags zu machen, weil es einfach so eine andere Lebenswelt war. Und dann bin ich dann die ganze Zeit mit so meinen Goodiebacks rumgelaufen, als wäre ich gerade einen Tag lang shoppen gewesen und hatte dann so Hemden geschenkt bekommen und so komische Vodafone-Pakete geschenkt bekommen und dann so Essen geschenkt bekommen. Und dann habe ich halt nachts noch was zu essen geholt und was zu trinken geholt. Du bist dann auch so ein klassischer Abstauber, ne? Klar, easy. Swag, stuff we all get. Ich habe auf so einer Feier dann immer zwei Ziele, möglichst viel Essen umsonst, möglichst viel umsonst geschenkt bekommen möglichst früh gehen möglichst früh gehen hat nicht funktioniert gott stefan das sind aber die anderen story das sind die stories die ihr nicht hört im podcast sondern die dann nur unsere praktikantin hört zum achten mal das ist dann unter tränen da habe ich mich auch der tanzler hier verloren das war auch ganz interessant jud Rackers auf der Tanzfläche zu sehen, weil die ganzen seriösen News-Channel haben ja auch Preise bekommen, die goldene Kamera. Und die waren danach alle sturzbedrungen auf der Tanzfläche. Und dann fängt an, die Welt zu bröckeln. Weil sobald du dann Karim Joska, Judith Rackers und Peter Klöppel auf der Tanzfläche siehst, wie die sich Wein oder Bier übers Dekolleté gießen und damit Rochel Gonzalez plötzlich auf der Tanzfläche stehen, dann zweifelst du ein bisschen an dem Wissen, was du von der Welt hast, was du nur durch die gewinnst. Ja klar, es ist ja so ein Medium, du erfährst durch die die Welt, wenn die uns so rechnungsfähig sind, denkst du dir, hm. Ja, die sind dann Schlüssel zur Welt und die plötzlich besaufen sich auf der Tanzfläche und fallen um, weil sie zu betrunken sind.
Dann denkt man, hm. Die sind dann Schlüssel zur Welt und die plötzlich besaufen sich auf der Tanzfläche und fallen um, weil sie zu betrunken sind. Dann denkt man, okay, wenn Michael Kessler Sturz betrunken auf der Tanzfläche steht und Luftgitarre spielt, denkst du, okay, das ist okay, das ist eine Comedyfigur, die hat das machen. Hugo Irgendwann darf an der Bar sitzen und auf dem Tresen kotzen, sprichwörtlich, aber Judith Rakes nicht. Aber auch diese ganze, diese ganze, ich hatte auch diese Halligallennummer mit Ryan Gosling, so eine coole Nummer alles, aber ich hatte tatsächlich streckenweise wirklich Mitleid mit der goldenen Kamera, weil das sind einfach arme Schweine. So natürlich, das weiss doch jeder seit Jahren, dass die Stars einladen, einfach um sie damit zu schmücken. Und es ist ja so, wenn wir über die goldene Kamera reden, das erste, worüber wir reden, ist Colin Farrell und die andere. So, das ist ja genau das. Wir sind ja in dieser Falle drin. Und jeder fragt ja, wenn du auf der Goldenen Kamera warst, frag dich, wie ist denn Colin Farrell so am Buffet? Was nimmt er sich als Erster? Das ist ja die erste Frage, das interessiert ja auch Leute. Das heißt, die Goldene Kamera tut ja nur dem Anspruch sozusagen Genüge, wenn sie solche Leute noch einlädt, auch verzweifelt.. Und jeder weiß, dass Leute den Preis kriegen, wenn sie ja gerade in der Gegend sind. Aber wir sind halt nun mal Deutschland, wir sind halt nun mal nicht Hollywood, wo du an jeder Ecke eine Emma Stone erwartest, sondern bei uns ist halt was Besonderes. Und deswegen kann ich das auch verstehen. Und natürlich ist es lächerlich, wenn die extra dafür dann auch denen auf jeden Fall einen Preis geben und so. Aber mein Gott, jeder weiß, dass wenn die Person gewinnt, die einfach nur da ist, ist ja klar, dass da keine große künstlerische Entscheidung dahinter stand. Deswegen ist es eine coole Aktion, war sehr lustig zu sehen, hat Spaß gemacht. Aber irgendwie dachte ich mir schon so, mein Gott, schlag doch nicht auf den Leuten um, die eh schon am Boden liegen. Mein Gott. Das Lustige war, dass Colin Farrell wohl, habe ich nachher gehört, neben mir stand an dem Buffet, wo das Süßigkeitenbuffet war, ich aber keine Augen für die Leute hatte drumrum, weil der Süßigkeitenbuffet der Wahnsinn war. Das war der Wahnsinn. Der eigentliche Star war das Süßigkeitenbuffet. Mega. Diese Veranstaltung hat man nur leider nicht gesehen. Krass, unangenehm. Nächstes Jahr räumen wir aber einen ab, oder? Nächstes Jahr räumen wir die goldene Kamera digital. Die goldene Kamera digital. Wir haben gegen Fresh Torge verloren. Er sagt das nicht so laut.
Naja.
Spürst du das, diese Ruhe?
Diese Ruhe, die wir gerade haben.
Das ist ein Feierabend, ne?
Ja.
Feierabend. So ein Bierchen?
Wie heißt Feierabendbierchen?
Glaubst du, diese Ruhe haben wir noch lange?
Glaubst du, wenn es mal irgendwann in guter Arbeit durch die Decke geht oder abgesetzt wird?
Glaubst du, da ist noch so eine Ruhe?
Wie sieht ein Feierabend von Stefan Tietze aus, also Tietze Tietze aus? Also du gehst nach Hause und dann, was passiert dann? Also du hast ja, wann gehst du ins Bett ungefähr? Relativ früh, 23 Uhr. 23 Uhr? 23 Uhr, 30, halb zwölf. Okay, dann hast du sagen wir noch ungefähr so drei Stunden, wenn du zu Hause bist. Wie wird das heute Abend aussehen? Also klar. Meistens komme ich nach Hause, meistens arbeite ich dann noch ein bisschen was, dann bestelle ich mir was zu essen währenddessen, komme dann zum Essen, wenn es kommt, setze mich damit vor den Fernseher, gucke noch eine spannende Serie oder ein, weiss ich, irgendwas, vielleicht surfe ich auch noch ein bisschen durchs Netz, schaue mir lustige Sachen an und dann ist es auch. Das war es dann schon, ne? Ja. Und dann gucke ich meistens noch, entweder habe ich dann noch eine Serie, die ich eine im Bett gucke, Serie oder ein im Bett Buch lese, Buch, oder habe dann da noch irgendwas, ich höre einen Podcast oder so, und dann schlafe ich ein. Und meistens um halb eins schlafe ich dann ein. Das heißt, ich habe eine Stunde, wo bin ich dann noch im Bett. Und so fließt das Leben dahin. Ja, oder? Aber ich dachte ja auch noch, was machen denn Menschen? Menschen haben nur noch Hobbys. Die treffen sich noch mit ihrem Schachclub, die gehen noch mal Sport machen, die gehen noch mal ins Fitnessstudio, die gehen noch mal spazieren oder sowas. Das finde ich ja gar nicht. Da habe ich auch keine Lust mehr zu. Die treffen sich mit Leuten. Wir reden den ganzen Tag mit Leuten. Da hast du auch abends keine Lust mehr, mit Leuten zu quatschen. Hast du noch Lust, abends mit Leuten zu quatschen? Nee. Einfach mal Ruhe haben, auch einfach mal alleine, einfach mal sagen. Was ist eigentlich so ein Fensterbrett? Ja. Hast du so eine Schublade, wo du ganz viele Quittungen drin hast und Gebrauchsanweisungen? Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt seit zwei Jahren oder so öffentlich keine Briefe mehr, die bei mir zu Hause ankommen. Ich mache die nicht auf, aber ich sammle die trotzdem alle und ich habe die auch alle. Ich habe ja so einen dicken, dicken Stoss Briefe bei mir zu Hause, aber ich mache die nicht auf. Weil ich habe mich ja nie, also ich habe mich ja umgemeldet, nachdem ich nach Berlin hierher gezogen bin. Und deswegen denke ich mir mal, alles, was wichtig ist, geht eh nach Berlin ins Nichts. Und zu mir kommt nur Crab, und das mache ich gar nicht auf. Aber wenn du mal irgendwann über Rot fährst und ein Knöllchen bekommst, wo kommt das dann hin? Ja, wenn dann da draufsteht, so von wegen Freundchen, Freundchen, Freundchen auf auf dem Briefumschlag aussen dran. Wenn er wichtig draufsteht. Dann wichtig, Komma, Freundchen, dann weiss ich schon, ah ja, okay, da ist die Bullerei wieder dahinter, irgendwie die Cops. Die Politessen. Nee, die Polizei. Und dann mache ich das natürlich schon auf, dann luge ich natürlich da schon mal rein. Du bezahlst dann aber nicht, weil du ein Rebell bist. Beim Duschkopf, hast du eine Einstellung? Wie? Jetzt reden wir, weißt du? Schau auf, goldene Kamera. Wir sind nicht die Menschen. Wie häufig wechselst du die Einstellung? Hast du einen Duschkopf, wo du so ein Rädchen hast? Klar, jeder hat die mittlerweile. Es gibt drei Einstellungen, Massage, das ist die Dicken, aka Masturbation, die Dicken in der Mitte, dann gibt es die Normalen und dann gibt es etwas, was ich nicht verstehe, was bei mir zu Hause so einen Spiraleffekt hat. What? Ja, mega fancy. Das hat so eine Spirale, das dreht sich so ein bisschen dann auch, wenn man das anmacht. Wenn man das betätigt, dann wird so ein Vorgang ausgelöst. Aber das ist unnötig. Wichtig ist der mittlere und ich benutze es nie anders. Na, ich nur den außen tatsächlich, ich benutze den äusseren Ring nur. Manchmal sind diese Duschköpfe auch so stark verkalkt, dass sie so unfassbar zentriert werden und unter so hohem Druck stehen, die Strahlen ja rauskommen, dass sie die wirklich ins Fleisch schneiden, die die wie so ein Laserskalpell einfach dann durch die Hautschicht abfetzen. Aber das finde ich gerade geil. Dieses Gefühl, wenn du gerade die Temperatur einstellst, schon mal die Dusche anmachst und dann aber noch neben der Dusche stehst, weil die Temperatur noch nicht stimmt, und dann, wenn es verkalkt ist und genau in dem Moment, obwohl du daneben stehst, so ein Strahl genau auf dich kommt, der die falsche Temperatur hat. Ich hasse diesen Einstrahl. Ich bin ja Duschkopfduscher. Also ich habe ja nicht den von oben runter, sondern ich habe den Duschkopf immer fest in der Hand. Und dann hältst du weg von dir dann? Halte ich dann weg von mir und dann tue ich da so die Hand durch, durch den Strahl und dann ballere ich mir den schön ins Gesicht. Wie sieht dein Badezimmer aus? Fühlen Sie mal durch dein Badezimmer. Es ist sehr klein, man geht rein, rechts ist ein Waschbecken, davor ist die Badewanne und die Dusche und es ist sehr eng. Und oft sitzt die Katze in der Badewanne, weil immer nachdem man geduscht hat, tropft der Hahn noch so ein bisschen. Was Hahn, die will ein bisschen was. Ja, und dann kommt die Katze immer, weil die hört das dann, dieses Tropfen. Ja, die hört das Leben. Und dann kommt die Katze rein, setzt sich in die Badewanne und guckt halt diesem tropfenden Wasserhahn zu. Und ich denke mir so, weißt du, Katze, du machst das jeden Tag. Irgendwann muss da doch das Interesse weg sein, weil du raffst doch, wie es läuft. Das tropft halt noch eine Weile und dann passt es auf. Da weißt du, wie spannend ihr Leben ist. Ja, das stimmt natürlich auch. Aber auf der anderen Seite, man denkt sich so, ja, irgendwann hat man es dann auch alles gesehen, aber vielleicht freut es sich. Ich meine, wir haben ja auch Routine, weil wie gesagt, du hast ja gerade gesagt, du schiebst dir jeden Tag deinen gleichen Shit rein. Und so, man hat natürlich seine Routine. Und vielleicht ist es für eine Katze auch so, dass sie einfach sagt, so geil, ich freue mich morgens, wenn der Fettsack duscht, dann kann ich danach rein und dann tropft das wieder. Ja, ich glaube, sie sagt Fettsack zu dir. Ja, kann schon sein. Aber das finde ich spannend, auch wie Haustiere, ich finde diese Videos toll, wo Haustiere mit einer GoPro versehen werden. Und dann zum ersten Mal sieht man ja, wie Tiere sind, wenn die Besitzer rausgehen. Da gibt es dieses Video von dem Hund, wie der sich verhält, wenn der Besitzer raus ist, mit einer GoPro auf dem Kopf, der einfach die ganze Zeit ein langweiliges Leben führt. Man denkt ja, der macht dann die Dinge, die er sonst nicht darf, aufs Bett gehen, auf die Tische springen und so, aber eigentlich liegt er die ganze Zeit nur rum und wartet, bis er wiederkommt. Ja, das macht ihm ja auch nur Spaß, wenn es verboten ist. Ich glaube, wenn die das einfach dürften, machen die es auch nicht. Ich glaube, die haben schon auch so diese verbotene Früchte. Aber hast du manchmal das Gefühl, wenn du alleine in so einer Wohnung bist, dass du was Verbotenes machen willst, dass du gerade was Unangebrachtes machen willst? Ja, schon ein bisschen. Das habe ich relativ häufig. Meinerseits springe ich auch mit Socken aufs Bett. Nee, das mache ich nicht, ist zu krass. Schlafen mit Socken oder ohne? Ohne. Ja, ohne. Mit Fenster auf oder ohne Fenster auf? Oh, Fenster auf, auf jeden Fall. Tür auf oder Tür zu? Tür Speerangel weit offen, so dass meine Mitbewohner schön den fetten Nacken Sack da liegen, sehen können jeden Tag. Ich glaube, ich habe in Berlin ein halbes Jahr in einem Studentenwohnheim gewohnt und am ersten Tag habe ich das Fenster gekippt und am Tag des Auszugs habe ich das Fenster zugemacht. Und die gesamte Zeit dazwischen war das Fenster die ganze Zeit offen, durchgehend, den ganzen Tag. Das war so ein Film aus Schweiß und Handcreme, verdunsteter, war dann daran, widerlich. Ja, aber es war eine schöne Zeit. Gerade wo ich, als ich an dich liegend gedacht habe, an Jabba the Hutt gedacht habe, warum schläft der eigentlich in seinem, in dem Palast da in so einem offenen Raum? Der ist der grösste, der ist wahrscheinlich der reichste Mensch aus der Galaxie. Warum man nicht ein eigenes Zimmer?
Aber schlafen Schnecken nicht sehr lange? Ist das Schnecke? Klar, Spaceschnecke. Aber ich glaube, das ist ja so die Idee, dass Schnecken extrem lange schlafen, dass sie teilweise sagen so, ach Leute, und dann elf Tage ratzen die weg und dann wachen die wieder auf und dann so, oh, weiter Schneckensachen machen. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach dieser kleine biologische Funfact hat George Lukey da einfach. Ah, Lucas wegen Luke, oder? Hat der Luke Skywalker nach sich selbst genannt wegen Lucas? Das glaube ich nicht. Glaube ich einfach nicht. Ich habe der Jabba nach seiner Oma benannt. Ja? Jabba, Jabba Lucas. Ja, ich glaube, da ist einfach da dieser Funfact rein.
Und ich glaube, die andere möglichen, also du kannst dich natürlich erwürgen.
Ich glaube, Lea hätte ihm aber auch einfach ganz viel Salz über den Kopf streuen können mit so einem Salzstreuer.
Und Schnecken vergnübt sich.
Und er einfach langsam, langsam vergangen, der aber da hat.
Ja, Jabba, ist auch komisch, dass er auf Frauen steht, weil Schnecken sind bisexuell, weil sie beide Geschlechter annehmen können.
Interessant.
Ja, eigentlich kein Geschlecht.
Kennst du den Ausdruck Weisses Gold für Salz? Heute würdest du ja sagen, Weisses Gold, ja klar, ist Kokain, Kokain, sage ich, Kokain, ein bisschen üb. Aber früher tatsächlich, das habe ich nie verstanden, es hieß immer früher, Salz hieß Weisses Gold. Ich habe auch so Funfact in meiner Familie, so immer wenn Salz genommen wurde, hieß es, genommen war. Wow. Ich hatte lange Zeit einen Salzstein. Ich war mal irgendwo auf so einem Bauernhof oder irgendwie so und da stand so ein Pferd rum. Ein Salzstein. Ja, und da stand so ein Pferd rum und Pferde haben ja immer einen Salzstein. Zum Lecken. Wo sie dran leckten. Und ich dachte mir, sowas will ich auch haben. Wenn so ein Pferd an so einem Salzstein leckt, will ich auch einen Salzstein haben. Dann hatte ich halt so einen Salzstein, den meine Eltern auf magische Weise hervorgezaubert haben. Ich glaube, das ist der Hauptskill von Eltern, dass einfach Probleme lösen. Kann ich einen Salzstein haben? Ja, einfach so ein Tuch auf dem Tisch ausbreiten, es wieder hochnehmen und dann ist da ein Salzstein drunter. Und dann habe ich den auch weggeleckt, über, glaube ich, bestimmt zwei Jahre. Du hast ihn weggeleckt? Über zwei Jahre hinweg habe ich diesen Stallstein weggeleckt. Aber du hast doch deinen Speichel dann immer jeden, der ist eingetrocknet dann auch und dann fängst du wieder an, daran zu lecken. Ja, du hast auch jeden Morgen den Speichel von letzter Nacht noch im Mund. Aber da tocknet doch einen, dann sind da Keime und in dem Mund kannst du die Keime ja kontroll Nein, der Mund ist mega rein. Nee. Na klar, Hundespucke ist sauberer als Leitungswasser. Ich glaube, es ist nämlich nicht so. Ja, komplett erfunden gerade. Ich glaube, es ist das Gegenteil. Exakt. Leitungswasser ist sauberer als ... Nee, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, man soll auch mit Hunden nicht küssen zum Beispiel. Ja, aber nur weil du on camera bist, Stefan. Ach so. Das hat was mit dem zu tun. Ja, weil plötzlich alle Müll ankamen. So, hör auf damit. Naja, aber ich hatte diesen Salzstein, ich habe den über zwei Jahre einfach weggeleckt. Und Weisses Gold hieß früher Salz. Ich habe es auch hin, weggeleckt zu werden. Jesus.. Jesus. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe mich immer gewundert, weisses Gold, weil Salz so selten war, früher im Mittelalter und so. Du hast auch lange Salz gesammelt und so in einem Schrank immer, wenn Salz über war, hast du immer gesammelt. Ist wertvoll. Aber dabei ist doch Salz im Meer. Also es ist doch mega heutzutage. Diese Geschichte hätte viele Turns nehmen können. dieser war unerwartet, muss ich sagen. Aber es ist doch mega, es ist doch gar nicht selten. Nein, aber ich bin tatsächlich, kannst du das so Wasser in zwei Händen halten, so in diesem Wasserschal? Ich kann das ganz schlecht. Ich bin auch nicht gut darin, ich kenne aber auch niemanden, der gut darin ist. Nee, aber ich konnte es immer früher meine Brüder immer so, geil, ich bin der Coolste, ich kann richtig viel Wasser in meinen Händen halten. Also wenn man die beiden Hände so zusammenfaltet. Ich kann Wasser aus einem Stadtbrunnen nach Hause bringen. Geil, ein bisschen mehr als du. Aber ich dachte mir, das wäre noch eine coole Schlag-den-Rab-Aufgabe. Beide kriegen so rote Flüssigkeit in die Hand und dann guckt man, bei wem das erste Mal einen Tropfen runter tropft. Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum die Sendung mittlerweile nicht mehr existiert. Weil Leute wie du angefangen haben, die Spiele zu helfen. Weil die einfach dann auch immer so Einsendungen bekommen haben von Leuten, hey, ein cooles Spiel wär doch irgendwie, man muss eine Stunde genau schätzen. Oh, nicht schlecht. Oder sowas. Dann müssen sie irgendwann sagen, jetzt. Gibt's aber schon für eine Minute oder so haben die gemacht, oder? Ist das nicht eine geile Gameshow? Wir suchen noch bei guter Arbeit. Erst wenn die Stunden beschätzt. Dann sitzen die da und nach einer Stunde müssen sie sagen, jetzt. Genau. Nee, nee, du darfst dich korrigieren. Vielleicht darfst du einmal besser einen Joker, weißt du vielleicht.
Ja.
Und du darfst einmal nach Zeit fragen.
Aber sonst ist die ganze Zeit die Stunde, ist einfach nur still.
Wie spät ist es?
Da denke ich mir auch dann so, im Publikum könnte doch jeder einfach so einen Komplizen sitzen haben, der dann einfach so sagt so.
Deswegen gibt es diese Chance auch nicht, oder?
Naja.
Ja, oder?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Auf jeden Fall gab es mal bei Schlag den Rapp dieses eine Spiel Menschenkenntkenntnis, wo zehn Menschen da saßen und dann hieß es immer die Frage, wie viele von denen waren schon mal bei einem Fussballspiel. Und dann mussten die die Anzahl schätzen, von eins bis zehn halt. Und meistens hat einer von denen auch gewonnen von den Spielern. Ach was. Ja, und ich frage mich immer, ob die das nicht beeinflussen konnten, die Leute, die da saßen. Die können einfach lügen. Weil sie ein Trikot getragen haben, meinst du das? Ja. Von ihrem Lieblingsverein. Ja, das stimmt. Ich finde auch lügen einfach. Das ist nicht sicher, das Spiel. Also würde ich nach dem nochmal gerne alles anfechten. Gameshows ausdenken ist bestimmt auch ein cooler Job eigentlich, oder? Weiß ich nicht. Würdest du gerne mal ein Brettspiel entwickeln, wenn dir zu mir auf die Zukunft und sag sagt so, hast du Bock auf ein Brettspiel? Ja, mega gerne. Ich habe ja immer noch die Idee für ein Spiel, aber ich kriege es nicht geknackt. Ich kriege es nicht geknackt. Okay, schau los. Und zwar stell dir einen Billardtisch vor. Ja, okay. Und stell dir bunte Kugeln vor. Okay. Und stell dir einen langen Holzstopp vor. Aber jetzt pass auf, du musst würfeln. nein, also stell dir einen Billardtisch vor und jetzt stell dir darauf drei Münzen vor, die in so einem Dreieck liegen. Und du musst immer da durch. Du musst immer da durch. Come on, das spielt doch jeder. Hä, aber gibt es denn Sinn des Spiels? Ja, du musst immer da durch. Naja, und dann immer abwechseln. Und wer zum ersten Mal daneben trifft, hat verloren. Wer zum ersten Mal auf die gegnerische Seite randotzt, mit einer Münze, hat gewonnen. Man muss sozusagen ein Tor schießen beim anderen. Aber man kann dem anderen ja auch die Schüsse mies machen, indem man die Münzen so legt, dass der keinen guten Move machen kann. Also ich finde es ein spannenderes Spiel. Du brauchst das Tor ja gar nicht. Du musst einfach immer ein Tor schießen. Es gibt drei Münzen, du musst immer ein Tor schießen. Und immerhin wurde jemand zum ersten Mal es schafft, kein Tor zu schießen, und hat der andere gewonnen. Das heißt, du musst am ehesten versuchen, so eine gerade Linie zwischen den drei Punkten zu erzeugen. Das ist besser. Naja, vielleicht funktioniert meine Idee auch. Probier das mal zu Hause. Ich wollte immer einen Billardtisch haben, aber das ist ein blöder Mensch. Ja, auch Billardtisch, geil. Ich glaube, so wie du einen Seilstand haben wolltest, wollte ich einen Billardtisch haben,
meine Eltern haben es nicht möglich gemacht.
Stattdessen gab es eine Tischtennisplatte. Lame! Kümmern wir mal ein Wasser auf. Willst du auch ein Wasser? Äh, aber leise bitte. Ja. Ah, dieses immer dieses krasse Wasser hier immer, das ist so, dieses Viva con agua.
Ja, ist gut.
Ist gutes Wasser.
Oh, wir haben noch Nüsschen.
Ah, komm, so Nüsschen.
Aber was ist denn dein Abend so?
Du kommst nach Hause,
das war auch nicht großartig anders, oder?
Hm.
Ja, jetzt ess mal auf. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt im Podcast auch nehmen.
Jetzt ess mal in Ruhe auf. Ich komme nach Hause und koche ich was, bläse ich noch was und dann spiele ich noch ein bisschen Klavier und dann gehe ich ins Bett.
Klavier? Was ist das Klavierbucke?
E-Piano, klar. E-Piano.
Da habe ich schon mal erzählt, klar. Mal spielst du da noch so? Tonleitern. Auf und runter. Ich spiele so viel Arme. Little Lip Stars, I did I'm going to be.
Ich bin ja faul, ich habe zum Beispiel auch lange Gitarre gespielt, aber ich habe nie wirklich Notenlesen gelernt. Also ich kann Notenlesen einigermaßen, aber sobald die diese oberste Linie oder unterste Linie verlassen, bin ich raus. Und ich weiß dann auch nicht, weil bei der Gitarre gibt es ja jeden Ton mehrmals auf verschiedenen Seiten, also dreimal, glaube ich. Das heißt, entweder hoch auf einer tiefen Seite oder so in der Mitte der nächsthöheren Seite zum Beispiel. Und das habe ich nie gerafft so. Also ich habe dieses Konzept natürlich schon verstanden, aber ich konnte nie intuitiv dann die Griffe anders greifen an einer anderen Position. Und das hat mich sehr erschwert, weil ich dann oft aus der Scham heraus, dass ich das nicht weiß, im Unterricht dann auch oft so getan hätte, als wüsste ich Bescheid und ich habe nie die Namen der Akkorde gelernt und so. Jetzt versuche ich bei Klavier wirklich erstmal die Basics zu lernen und so wirklich so eine Schaltung von ich sehe die Note und weiss sofort, wo auf dem Klavier die ist, dass ich auch blind spielen kann oder so und dann erst versuche, Stücke zu lernen. Und das ist echt fucking nervig und anstrengend. Ja. Lass das mal. Das ist so anstrengend. Aber ist das so, dass man, wenn man Gehirnarbeit verrichtet, also mit dem Gehirnenergie verbrennt, das ähnlich ist wie Sport? Oder ist das ein Quatsch? Ist das ein Jux? Weil ich rede mir ein, ich mache seit ein paar Jahren keinen Sport mehr, also null, null Sport, und ich habe nicht wirklich viel zugenommen. Ob das damit zusammenhängt, dass man einen Job macht, wo man relativ viel nachdenken muss. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Es heißt ja auch so, dass das Gehirn die meisten Kalorien verbraucht, von allen Organen und so. Aber was heißt denn dann, wenig Gehirnaktivität gegen viel Gehirnaktivität? Also wenn du jetzt eine Serie schaust, würde ich jetzt eher mal sagen, du hast eine geringe Genaktivität, weil du passiv bist. Es sei denn, du brauchst eine sehr schwierige Serie.
So Blues Clues oder sowas.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Wo du mitredst.
Wo du raten musst.
Und dann denkst du auch, fuck, was war jetzt der Hinweis?
Eis!
Nein, ein Hinweis!
Ah, jetzt geht der in die Feuerwelt!
Nein!
Ja, sowas, aber ich kann es auch schwer sagen, es ist schwer zu sagen, weil bei mir ist es oft so, dass selbst wenn ich nur passive Sachen mache, ich viel nachdenke, auch viel unnötig nachdenke. Deswegen weiß man nicht genau, was sind denn dann schwierige Gedanken und was sind leichte Gedanken. Wenn du zum Beispiel überlegst, so was esse ich heute zum Mittag, ist es jetzt schwerer, als wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie 40 mal 38 rechnen musst. Ist das jetzt schwieriger als wenn du sagst, okay, keine Ahnung, was hatte ich gestern nochmal für eine Hose an? Du meinst, du setzt gerade gleich, dass es entweder keine Gehirnaktivität gibt oder Gehirnaktivität. Und stellst du mal in Frage, ob es verschiedene Stufen hat. Nee, das wird wahrscheinlich schon eine Skala sein, aber was unterscheidet denn leichte Gedanken von schweren Gedanken? Bei Bewegung ist klar, je schneller du läufst, desto anstrengender ist es, desto mehr Kalorien verbrauchst du. Oder je mehr Gewicht du hebst, aber was ist das denn bei Gedanken dann? Ich weiß auch nicht, ich würde auch mal in Frage stellen, dass ein Fussballer weniger Gedanken verbrennt als ich zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, es ist ähnlich, wenn er jetzt über räumliches Denken nachdenkt und wo muss ich den Pass hinspielen, bis Thomas vom FCB den reinmacht, vorne, einfach dasige in die Säcke geht. Ja, aber ist es dann zum Beispiel, hat ein dummer Mensch, verbraucht er dann mehr Kalorien mit den gleichen Gedanken, weil er das ineffektivere Gehirn hat sozusagen als ein kluger Mensch? Hat er einen höheren Threshold, wie er jetzt ein Sportler wahrscheinlich auch mehr leisten muss, um die gleiche Kalorienverbreitung hinzukriegen wie ein fetter Mensch, der einen weniger effektiven Körper hat. Ich glaube, verbrennen 100 Meter Sprinter auch beim 100 Meter Sprint weniger als ich beim 100 Meter Sprint? Naja, klar, weil er schneller ist. Aber wenn jetzt die gleiche Strecke in der gleichen Zeit läuft, glaube ich, wird der Athlet weniger Kalorien verbrennen. Weil das ist ja die Idee, dass der Körper Muskeln effektiver macht, wenn er merkt, die werden häufig benutzt. Oder das ist doch die Idee, deswegen wachsen doch Muskeln. Die reissen dann, die Muskeln reissen, das ist Muskelkater, und dann bildet sich das neu, dann bildet sich die Phase neu in verstärkter Form. Ja, das ist Muskelaufbau. Hat jetzt keine Frage beantwortet, die du gestellt hast? Ich hatte als Kind einen Kumpel, bei dem war es andersrum, der hat, wenn er sich angestrengt hat, Muskeln abgebaut.
Und das ist echt eine scheisse Situation. Und der war einfach der grösste Muskelprotz.
Du saß faul in der letzten Reihe.
Ja, aber der hat sozusagen gestartet mit ganz vielen Muskeln.
Als Bodybuilder.
Und hat immer weniger ab, also anders als vielleicht andere im Leben.
Aber das war echt weird, weil er dachte sich halt so, ja, wenn ich jetzt halt renne, dann verliere ich halt Muskeln, die kriege ich nie wieder. Das ist halt wie bei so einer Lebensenergie. Du musst halt deine Lebensenergie einteilen für den Rest des Lebens. Stimmt, du musst ja eine Muskelmasse einteilen. War das denn ein Defekt oder habt ihr das scherzhaft behauptet? Das, glaube ich, haben die Ärzte eben auch Scheiss gesagt. Ich glaube, das war nur ein Ulk. Deswegen, glaube ich, mag ich das nicht, seriöse Berufe auszuüben wie ein Todwissenschaftler oder so. Scherze kommen nicht gut an. N du mal in diesem Forschungs-Papier... Gags im Forschungspapier habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Nee. Aber es gibt ja auch so die Theorie, dass man nur eine gewisse Art von Herzschlägen, eine Anzahl von Herzschlägen hat in seinem Leben, und man die halt irgendwann verbraucht hat. Krasse Theorie. Ach so meinst du das? Und wenn du halt auch überliebt bist oder so, dann hast du halt echt ein Problem. Dann sagen sie so, scheiße. Ja, aber wenn du Schauspieler bist und immer nervös bist, weil du dich in Ausnahmesituationen bringst, auf der Bühne, dann lebst du ja auch weniger, weil der Puls sich erhöht. Oder als Sportler, das ist eine dumme Theorie, Sportler leben noch länger. Weiß ich nicht, die gehen auch kaputt, oder? Ist es nicht so, dass Sportler nach ihrer Karriere total kaputt sind einfach und dann irgendwie auch körperlich schlechter dastehen als normale Menschen? Ich glaube, wir begegnen uns gerade in einem Terrain, wo wir nicht unbedingt hingehören. Das ist wie in so einem Videospiel, wenn man in der Zone ist, wo man nicht hingehört und dann wird man zurück teleportiert. So, ah, redet mal lieber wieder über Penisse und über Duschköpfe. Das macht GTA Vice City schlau, weil am Anfang die Meldung kommt, in Radios, dass die Brücken gesperrt sind aufgrund einer Unwetterbahnung.
So, dann macht das Spiel aber nicht richtig, dass es irgendwie anfängt, das Wetter auch anzugleichen, sondern es ist meistens halt einfach Miami, Florida Wetter.
Geil, alles ist Sonne, überall fahren Rollergirls lang, alles cool und eigentlich sind alle Brücken trotzdem gesperrt.
Naja, Trottel.
Idioten Rockstar Games. Habe ich mir jetzt mal wieder runtergeladen. GTA Vice City ist für mich das beste GTA. Ich liebe GTA Vice City, ich finde diese ganze Stimmung, die das verbreitet, total geil. Ich finde es cool, die Musik finde ich cool, ich finde die Autos cool, ich finde die Stadt cool, alles cool. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass auch so die Grafik-Engine der Realität irgendwie so ein bisschen hinterherhängt. Hast du nicht mal das Gefühl, dass du denkst, du siehst so Häuserfassaden und du denkst so, komm, dahinter ist doch nichts. Oder? So von wegen, also wenn ich da jetzt reingehe, da ist da nichts drin. Weil du hast ja immer nur so diese Pargebäude, du gehst vom Supermarkt nach Hause, Arbeit, Supermarkt nach Hause, Arbeit. Du hast nur ein Pargebäude mit 3D gefüllt. Genau, die sind halb betretbar. Und die anderen NSCs, wo die da alle hinlaufen, weißt du einfach nicht so. Und dann gehst du da rein und wenn du eine gute Engine hast, dann generiert die das schon. Aber wenn du jetzt ganz schnell wohin laufst, ich glaube, wenn du jetzt von hier aufstehst und ganz schnell irgendwo hinrennst, womit die Engine nicht rechnen konnte und du einfach die Tür aufmachst, dann kann es sein, dass du dann irgendwie so einfach so graues Wabern siehst oder so. Ist ja manchmal so, dass Gespräche mit Fremden seltsam sind.
Und ich glaube, wenn sie wirklich seltsam sind, dann hast du einfach zu früh diesen Menschen
in deinem Level angesprochen. Der ist noch nicht dafür bereit.
Das ist auch wie, wenn du bei Pokémon bestimmten Leuten ansprichst, die dir noch nichts
zu sagen haben, dann wiederholen sie sich. Oder dann sagen sie Dinge, die uninteressant
sind, die du nicht wissen willst, die bisschen awkward. Die Gespräche, wenn du Pokémon
führst am Anfang, wenn du dich mit jedem sprichst, immer in der Stadt, sind die immer
Vielen Dank. Oder dann sagen sie Dinge, die uninteressant sind, die du nicht wissen willst, die bisschen awkward. Die Gespräche, wenn du Pokémon führst am Anfang, wenn du mit jedem sprichst in meiner Stadt, sind die immer ein bisschen awkward. Die wiederholen sich auch so und die sind alles ein bisschen seltsam, die erzählen die Dinge, die willst du nicht wissen. Ich glaube auch, dass das das große Problem von Quantenphysik ist, weil je detaillierter die Naturwissenschaft, die Materie versucht zu erforschen, desto mehr stösst sie auf Hindernisse, weil die Realität noch nicht existiert. Die muss erst noch konstruiert werden, weil die Realität nie damit gerechnet hat, dass der Mensch so weit kommt. Ja, passt schon, fick dich, Atome. Und dann, fuck Scheiße, die kriegen Atome raus. Denkt immer irgendwas aus, was da runter ist, so Quarks Scheiß. Aber weiter geht's noch nicht. Das heißt, ich glaube, wir müssen einfach ein bisschen warten, bis die Realität sozusagen nachzieht, bis dieser Buffer.
Ich glaube einfach, String-Theorie ist so eine Art Buffer-Theorie, dass man sagt so, ja, halt die mal hin, bis wir uns was Besseres ausgedacht haben.
Ich habe mir bei Westworld gedacht.
Also das ist ja nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass wir mal irgendwann Leben kreieren aus der.
Ja, wurde doch jetzt gemacht mit so einem kleinen ekelhaften Fleischbällchen, das dann durch die Gegend gelaufen ist. Krass, ja. Also das ist ja nicht unwahrscheinlich. Und es ist auch evolutionstheoretisch, glaube ich, nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass das Leben, was wir kreieren, perfekter ist als das Leben, wo wir kreiert wurden. Und angenommen, man springt das mal weiter, wenn das Leben perfekter ist, wird es unser Leben vernichten irgendwann, weil es durchsetzungsfähiger ist. In dem Moment, wo das passiert, glaube ich, hat sich eine neue Welt gebildet, ein neuer Mensch. Und was, wenn das schon mal so war? Was, wenn wir auch nur, wenn wir das vernichtet haben, was vor uns war? Und es war ja auch so in gewisser Weise. Und stell dir mal vor, es gibt Alienrassen, die krass weit sind und weiterentwickelt sind, weil Leute wie wir die entwickelt haben. Das kann gut sein. Ich habe letztens die Doku von Werner Herzog gesehen, über Vulkane, richtig coole Doku, die auch mega abschweift in ganz hohe Ecken. Wo die in Nordkorea sind. Ja genau, und der hat auch seinen Teil über Archäologie und Menschheitsforschung, Anthropologie. Und da meint ja auch dieser eine Forscher, der diese Knochen sucht in der Wüste,
der meinte auch, dass es mal eine Zeit gab in der Menschheitsgeschichte, wo es irgendwie nur noch 400 Menschen gab.
Und es locker gewesen sein könnte, dass der Mensch einfach ausgestorben wäre.
Weil wenn die 400 halt irgendwie Krippe gehabt hätten oder gesagt haben, ach komm, jetzt Fortpflanzung, so hübsch ist die auch nicht, dann war es das einfach. Dann. Aber die haben es tatsächlich auf die Reihe gekriegt, die Fackel weiterzutragen, sodass es uns heute sieben Milliardenfach gibt. Gibt es eine Art und Weise, dass die Menschen in der Welt die Menschen in der, der Mensch entwickelt sich nicht mehr weiter. Also wir verbessern uns ja nicht mehr, weil die Gesellschaft immer liberaler wird. Und in dem Moment, wo wir halt jeden akzeptieren, wie er ist und es kein Ellenbogen mehr ist, was die Natur ja ist, die ja eigentlich... Klar, natürlich ist genau das gleiche Ellenbogen. Du suchst deinen Geschlechtspartner immer noch aus. Ja, aber die Leute bleiben ja nicht mehr über. Ja, aber nach anderen Kriterien natürlich. Schwache Leute bleiben ja auch nicht mehr alleine, wie damals in der Natur. Kranke Leute sterben nicht mehr einfach. Der Schwächere, der in der Natur ausgesiebt wird, weil er nicht überlebt, weil er sich nicht fortpflanzt, der wird nicht mehr aus. Ja gut, aber das ist halt ein weiteres Witz der Evolution. Das ist ja nicht notwendigerweise schlechtere Evolution. Das habe ich gesagt. Ich habe nur gesagt, das ist wahrscheinlich, wir verändern die gerade massgeblich. Und ich glaube, du kannst dich ja nur verändern, indem du falsifizierst, indem du Leute aussiebst, die sich nicht fortpflanzen, indem die Stärksten überleben. Und in dem Moment, wo wir das jetzt nicht mehr machen, sondern wo wir anfangen, jeden mitzunehmen, auch ein Dicker, der sonst auf der Strecke bleiben würde. Ja, aber der pflanzt sich dann vielleicht nicht fort, weil er zu fett ist. Klar wird das passieren. Also ich meine, dafür ist die Gesellschaft ja viel zu liberal, dass solche Leute irgendwie keinen Partner abbekommen oder sowas. Das ist immer eine interessante Statistik, wie viel Prozent der Bevölkerung sich tatsächlich fortpflanzt und wie viel nicht. Genau, und wer? Und ich glaube, es ist einfach... Und wer? Ich will Namen! Ja, ich will Namen, weil ich will wissen, welcher, ich glaube, der exakte Querschnitt der Menschheit pflanzt sich auch fort. Steine These, okay, aber ich glaube, und das hindert einfach gerade, dass auch Behinderte pflanzen sich fort, was in der Natur nicht möglich gewesen wäre, und deswegen, weil dank neuer Technologien und was auch immer, und deswegen, glaube ich, verhindert uns gerade daran, bessere Menschen zu werden, weil wir das gestoppt haben. Würdest du sagen, deine Gene sind es wert, weitergetragen zu werden? Also angenommen jetzt mal rein die hypothetische Theorie, dass du keinen Geschlechtspartner findest, würdest du dann irgendwann sagen, ey, fuck you, das ist unfair, ich habe überdurchschnittlich gute Gene, die müssen weitergebracht werden, wir müssen der Menschheit helfen mit meinen Genen, oder würdest du sagen, zum Glück bin ich raus aus dem Pool? Zu gross, Trichterbrust, verschiedene andere Behinderungen, Krebs vorbelastet, Herzinfarkt vorbelastet, ich glaube, meine Gene sind es wert, weitergetragen zu werden. Auf jeden Fall weiter. Leute sollen krepieren. Leute sollen die gleichen Erfahrungen machen wie ich. Die scheisse gehen wie ich. Klar. Ich glaube schon, dass es wert ist. Weißt du, auch wenn ich es körperlich nicht so habe, hier oben. Ich denke nach. Ich denke über Dinge nach.
Stefan hat gerade auf seine Kopfhörer gekriegt. Die sind es wert, weiter getreut zu werden.
Ich hatte heute lange Zeit aus Versehen deine Kopfhörer an, übrigens.
Ach, fuck you. Sorry.
Was hast du gehört? Hast du meine Sachen gehört?
Nee, ich habe meine Sachen gehört.
Du hast meine Tele... Wie das denn?
Ich habe mich eingehackt in deine Kopfhörer.
Aber wir haben dasselbe Modell. Aber angenommen, mein Telefon wäre gegangen, hättest du mein Telefon gehört. Er hat sich in der Zeit, dass er die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt, die die Welt aus mit neuen T-Shirts? Uns wurden neue T-Shirts-Design geschenkt. Das interessiert dich überhaupt nicht, ne? Das interessiert den Scheiß.
Doch, Smisma habe ich gesehen.
Ja, Smisma. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Smisma-Einsendungen.
Vielen Dank auch an Leute, die dieses Run-DMC-Logo sehr gut verstanden haben und Smisma in einer Zeile geschrieben haben.
Ja, auch aus dem Schreibschrift.
Die Idee von Run-DMC ist, dass es zwei Zeilen sind.
Einmal Run und dann DMC.
Aber vielen Dank trotzdem an alle. Vielen Dank dafür. Ihr seid einfach die Besten. Hast du einen Tipp für uns? Irgendwie einen Tipp, was man so machen kann, mal unternehmen kann, was man mal abends machen kann? Neben Kino gehen zum Beispiel. Hast du da mal einen Tipp? Wo kann man hingehen, was gibt es zu erleben, wo willst du mal gerne hin, was willst du, was ist.
Ich fände es cool, wenn ich irgendwie so eine, so was wie ein Museum oder ein Theater oder ein Konzertheller hatte, wo ich mich richtig gut auskenne. Früher, als ich in München war, da war ich irgendwie, jedes Wochenende war ich im Residenztheater in München und irgendwann fängt man an, man lernt die Leute kennen, irgendwie die Garderobiers, man lernt, man begrüsst sich, man kennt den Spielplan auswendig, man kennt den Intendant so ein bisschen, man weiß die verschiedenen Regisseure, die Schauspieler, man hat so eine Verbindung, das ist so eine erweiterte Familie.
Und das ist eigentlich schön, da habe ich mir gestern eigentlich darüber gedacht, dass ich mir das so ein bisschen vermisse, dass ich nicht so in dieses Städtische mit eingebunden bin, so die verschiedenen Institutionen der Stadt, irgendwie so das Museum und dann so, ah, dieses neue Theaterstück, jetzt irgendwie das Furore, man ist da völlig raus, so, ich hab gemerkt, ich bin überhaupt nicht mit der Stadt im Einklang, so, ich bin völlig abgekapselt davon, ich weiß gar nicht, was los ist und, kleiner Spoiler, vielleicht ziehe ich bald um innerhalb von Köln und wohne dann in der Nähe des Hauptbahnhofs, wo ja auch die große Konzerthalle ist und das Ludwig-Museum und so und auch viele Leute. Und dann dachte ich mir so, vielleicht kann man sich dann mal so ein bisschen mehr ins Stadtleben werfen, irgendwie mal so gucken, so internationale Musikstars, so Komponisten, Klassiker, irgendwie, vielleicht sind die dann auch mal in Köln und man kriegt das alles gar nicht mit, vielleicht haben wir irgendwie schon krasse Jahrhundertkonzerte, Jahrhundertphänomene verpasst. Und man einfach sagt so, ey, wo war der denn 2008, als irgendwie Young Bang Tsao seine einmalige Vivaldi-Interpretation gegeben hat und man denkt sich so, ja, ich hab da irgendwie True Detective gesehen. Geile Serie. Statt euch True Detective an. Die erste Staffel ist richtig gut, über die zweite Staffel können wir reden in einem separaten Chatroom, den ich momentan einrichte. Oh, würdest du das gerne mal machen? Ja. So eine Service-Seite, so ein Chatbot, was für dich schreibt, wie du schreiben würdest. Ich will ja nicht mit den ganzen Leuten schreiben, aber ich würde gerne jemanden haben, der wie ich mit den Leuten schreibt. Meine Meinung vertritt und meine Meinung, die Argumente gewinnt, weil es einfach ein guter Chatbot ist. Ich versuche, weg von Meinung zu kommen. Ich versuche, keine Meinungen zu haben. Die Welt ist voller Meinungen, alle haben Meinungen. Irgendwie... Naja, gut, das ist ja alles fake hier so, aber so privat versuche ich mich immer weiter, ich versuche mich weiter im Ignorieren zu üben, so einfach so Dinge wahrnehmen, aber keine Meinung dazu haben, so man hat eh keine Ahnung von gar nichts, man hat keine Ahnung, so gerade so Politik und so, das ist dann so ja man hat doch keine Ahnung von dem Ganzen es war doch schon oft schon oft so, dass man sich denkt so, ja dieses, was weiß ich, irgendwie Irakkrieg ist total schlecht. Und dann sieht man eine Doku und man sagt, nee, stimmt, das ist total scheiße. Dann sieht man eine neue Doku und dann sagt man, ja, stimmt, das ist total scheiße. Ja, ist zynisch. Und dann hört man so eine Talkshow, wo man denkt, ja okay, ich habe einfach keine Ahnung. In den Gebieten, in denen ich Ahnung habe, so keine Ahnung, jetzt wenn man mich fragt, zu welcher DSA-Zauber ist der beste, da kenne ich mich aus,
da kann ich eine valide, sinnvolle Meinung dazu abgeben. Welcher ist der beste? Kulminatio.
Ist eine gute Meinung, kann ich abgeben,
da kann ich was zu sagen, aber dann zu anderen Sachen
kommen. Aber es ist zynisch,
weil du dich dann am Weltgeschnitten
beteiligst. Ne, was heißt beteiligen?
Ne, ich nehme das wahr, ich versuche so viel zu verstehen,
wie es geht, wie es mich interessiert,
aber ich versuche die Meinung Leuten zu überlassen, die sich damit auskennen. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Meinung. Das ist das Zeitalter der Meinung. Zeitalter, dass jeder hat seine Meinung. Das ist es, glaube ich, eher. Ich glaube, es ist eine sehr populäre Meinung, die du gerade vertrittst. Keine Meinung haben. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Das ist doch genau dieses Twitter-Ding. Leute haben keine Meinung mehr, Leute schreiben über das Thema, machen das, über das Thema Gags, über das sich gerade geschickt, Gags zu machen. Ich glaube, es ist einfach so., und dann die haben keine Meinung dazu. Ich glaube, alle haben eher so eine ironisch distanzierte Haltung zu Dingen. Also ich glaube, die wenigsten regen sich wirklich über Trump auf, die meisten Leute fragen sich, wie können sie einen Tweet darüber machen, dass man sich über Trump aufregt. Ja. Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, auch das ist eine scheisse Meinung. Alles ist Das ist alles schon eine Scheissmeinung. Das stimmt. Naja.
Ciao.
Vielen Dank für eure... Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, wenn es wieder heisst, das Podcast-Ufo hebt ab.
Schlägt Zug.
Bald gibt's übrigens eine Titelmelodie.
Intro.